of january
2021 my name is councillor
mrs jeanette stiltz and i am chairman of
this committee
this meeting is being held under new
regulations
which come into effect on the 4th of
april in response to the kovic 19
situation there are just a few
housekeeping issues to run through
first of all could i please ask
everybody present in this meeting to
ensure your microphone
remains muted when not addressing the
committee
this will reduce background noise and
avoid any and
intentional disturbances this meeting is
being hosted remotely streamed live
and recorded and by being presence in
this meeting you are giving your consent
to being recorded
members and officers during each item
please use the hands up function
of the meeting to indicate you wish to
speak i will then invite you at the
appropriate time
members are reminded that apart from
indicating points of
order or that you have to leave the
meeting
the chat function should not be used for
any other
questions right
when speaking and referring to agenda
item
papers please ensure that you refer
reference a
page or paragraph number keep your
contributions as clear and concise as
possible
when invited to speak please ensure you
turn on your microphone and video
now if i may ask officers taking part in
the meeting to introduce themselves
starting with mr leslie
good afternoon chris leslie director of
resources
mrs miss cardi
do we have miss cardi no um
she's not here just yet yes sorry i was
just struggling
with my camera
that's fine missy's uh miss donnelly
no she's here yeah emma donnelly video
internal audit manager
thank you uh miss holmes
good afternoon emma holmes senior legal
specialist
thank you mr rubens
good afternoon greg rubin's partner bdo
internal audience
and berna good afternoon members banner
casey clark to the committee
are there any other officers present at
this meeting
yeah yeah good afternoon members cheryl
hughes programs performance and
governance manager
thank you cheryl i don't know where you
were we were on my list sorry
um before i call on the clerk to take a
roll call of committee members
can i please ask those councillors in
attendance to introduce themselves
please suburna can you now carry out a
call of committee members
to confirm who is in attendance thank
you
thank you lemon members i will call your
names in alphabetical order starting
with counselor channel
uh present um berna i'm here
and uh good afternoon everyone cancer
head
present good afternoon everyone thank
you councillor helm
president thank you thank you council
hall
a present by now thank you and hello
everybody
jarvis afternoon burner chairman
councillors
thank you cancer keys
good afternoon berman chairman and
councillor so happy
hello thank you castle nunn
good afternoon and everyone thank you
thank you council shaughnessy
uh here but uh good afternoon everyone
thank you thank you cast a stamp um yeah
good afternoon burner and everybody else
i i'm present as well thank you
i'm casting stilts good afternoon
thank you thank you chairman okay um may
i have any apologies for absence please
berna
uh german we've got a full house this
afternoon thank you
thank you burner item three on the
agenda
sorry karen sorry sorry chairman um
just to say that uh council morris is uh
in attendance good afternoon sorry
councillor maurice i was
should have said is there any other
councillors present that would like to
make themselves known so thank you
and apologies i've not got the hand up
function so i couldn't do it that way
sorry to
interrupt thank you guys that's fine
so if there's no other members of
councillors
present we will go on to agenda item
three minutes of
the last meeting on the 26th of november
2020
it is recommended that the minutes of
the meeting held on the 26th of november
found on pages 5-14 are approved as true
and accurate record so i give you
page five six
seven six page six please chairman yes
i just wanted where it says 109
uh three paragraphs down uh it talks
about the chairman and i think it's put
he
instead of she i think that's referring
to yourself am i right
um let me just i would imagine
it is
i think could be the internal audit
partner
yes i think that refers to me yeah all
right yes it does
yes thank you
so are you happy with page six
chairman i am thank you thank you so
i'll give you page seven
page eight
page nine page 10
and page 14.
iso move if you wish to second that
motion please turn on your video
unmute your microphone and state your
name now
councillor heard happy two seconds thank
you councillor heard
sorry all right
um it's all right just catching up i
will now take a
vote taking each member in alphabetical
order
or are you happy to take it um
by a cent agreement agreed
great
are you happy with that burner yes thank
you chair
thank you um item a gen
a gender item for declaration of
interest to disclose
the existence of nature of any
disposable peculiar interests
other peculiar interests or
non-pecuniary interests relating to
items of business on the agenda having
regards to paragraph
628 inclusive of the code of conduct for
members members are reminded that they
are
also required to disclose any such
interests as soon as they become aware
should the
need arise throughout the meeting if
any member has interest to declare
please use the hands up function now
to indicate and i will invite you to
speak counselor
china thank you chairman
it's my normal one chairman i will
declare non-pecuniary interest
as a member of essex county council
bearing in mind some of the linkages i
think with in
the uh reports thank you thank you
councillor channel
does anybody else have any
interest no
i will move on then item 5
public participation i can advise
that we have not received any
submissions from members of the public
so i will move on to item six before we
start
item six can i ask mr leslie to give a
quick
overview of fees which i know is on
a lot of councillor's mind as it has
been brought up for the external
auditors so if i could ask mr leslie to
present
that for me
yeah thank you yeah just give a recap
of some of the activity around this so
on the 24th of september the pga
committee received a letter
from the auditors uh regarding their
fees uh for the year
the letter also included proposed fees
uh for the following year
uh those fees were nearly a hundred
thousand pounds uh almost doubling
the fees for this year of fifty thousand
uh discussions have taken place
subsequently
with myself uh the then chair and the
vice
chair of the pga committee with the
external orders to voice their
concerns around the large increase in
fees and ask that this is referred to
the public sector audit appointments
who agree uh the external audit fees
their response is due back at the end of
january and we'll be discussing
that with the external auditors
afterwards due to the pressures in the
audit market
and increased audit requirements the
government and the public sector audit
appointments
have stated that audit fees for local
government will
increase i'm happy to take any questions
thanks chair thank you
there any questions for mr leslie no
i will move on then so
thank you for that mr leslie uh we will
now move
on to the internal audit report progress
sector update
followed up by recommendations
so these reports can be found on page 15
to 58
in a moment i will call on officers to
present this item
members a reminder that if you wish to
speak on this item please and make it
known by using the hands up function
within this meeting
i will then come to you in turn
please keep your points clear and
succinct
members the first three reports will be
presented by mr rubin's
and the second two by miss donnelly from
bdo
mr rubins would you like to present your
report please
yes thank you chairman so um if i just
first cover the progress report on page
19 of your papers
you'll see um that we've got two audits
we're presenting to you today that have
been finalized and ms donnelly will
present those
um after i finish um and we've also
um finalized for this year the work we
were doing with officers
on supporting them around the new leases
accounting standard
um so overall we've got we've finalized
five out of 11 pieces of work probably
slightly behind where i'd like to be
at this time of year but given that we
had the delays caused by covid at the
start
i think it's a reasonable position we
have two other audits underway
and we have the resources in place to
complete
our work in the normal time scale so um
you know uncomfortable we'll be able to
give the normal head of internal audit
opinion
in the normal time scales um the only
other things i was going to mention
um the sector update i think speaks for
itself so i'm obviously
happy to take any comments on that on
the follow-up
uh reports uh you'll see on the whole
again
we've got good progress uh that's page
32 of your papers
uh but you'll see on page 33 we still
have one
recommendation outstanding which relates
to the climate change and waste strategy
uh you had an update on that in the last
meeting and we're still waiting for that
strategy to be finalized and it's been
delayed due to operational pressures
um so overall i think a reasonable
position
um i will pause there for any questions
but not on the two reports if i can just
emphasize if you can just wait
for miss donnelly to present the
workforce and the
information management report she'll
then take questions after that but i'm
happy to take any comments or questions
at this stage on the
progress sector update and follow up
thank you mr uh rubens is there any
questions
from the councillors for mr rubin's
mr hurd councillor heard sorry
thank you chairman i just need to ask um
a question
about uh about the safeguarding is if
that's
uh if that's not preempting mr donnelly
no that's fine um we spoke about a lead
specialist being appointed and uh
the the the this district council
has an approved list of contractors
which will be subjected to
dbs checks um it's given a level
of moderate assurance
and yet the completion date is at the
end of
the year the end of this year uh what
can you tell me what has happened
between
july july 20 and november 21
please i think there might be one for
officers to answer but i think this came
up at the last meeting
i think their members did express some
uh concerns about the length of time
needed to
to to um complete that particular
recommendation and i think what was
agreed
was that officers would present a more
detailed action plan as to how to
uh as to show progress over that period
and we as internal audit will
review that and comment on that so i i
think it's for officers to
to respond on that but we're obviously
ready to do that for the next meeting if
if that plan is ready
thank you mr evans uh mr councillor
heard we have
no offices other than mr leslie and
cheryl present mr holmes and uh mr
dobson are not present at this meeting
well if i could just come back on that
the the the reason that i asked was
about the level of assurance are we
happy with moderate uh and that's
mr rubens uh
yes i mean we we we explained that again
last time as to why we thought that was
uh moderate we thought overall there
were reasonable processes in place
uh and a number of sort of mitigating
controls to make sure
um that there's no you know abuses take
place but
um you know again we need to see the
actions
uh um that come that show the
recommendations been implemented
okay all right thank you very much thank
you councillor
um if there's no other questions for mr
rubin's i'll move on to miss donnelly to
present her report okay
i will move on to page 36 of the pack
which is the workforce management
report this was a substantial and audit
um opinion and this we thought that we
undertook
a review of the council's workforce
strategy and plan
the strategy linked to the objectives
within the council's corporate plan
and also aligned to the medium-term
financial plan and i.t strategy
and and there were this means that it's
allowing to achieve objectives
in the corporate plan and the people
workforce development strategy is
supported by action plans
to support recruitment and resourcing
retention
learning and development and employee
engagement action plans are monitored
through the hr service plan
we find that there was an action plan in
place to support the issues raised
in response to the staff survey and an
updated plan will be produced in
february 2021
managed by the clt overall we found
clear direction
and appropriate oversight over the
implementation of the workforce
and strategy and there was an
appropriate response to the impact of
covert against the actions in place and
therefore we
provide substantial assurance
any questions on the workforce report
do i have any questions for mr donnelly
does it look like
so good i'll move on to the information
management report which is on page 47 of
the pack
this was a medium medium assurance level
report
and the purpose of the audit was to
assess the design and effectiveness of
where the council's
information management controls and
processes for the storage retention and
destruction of paper documents so we
focused on
paper rather than digital documentation
this time to support compliance with the
council's document retention schedule
and current legislation and we find that
the council had identified and recorded
its information assets and has a
detailed information asset register in
place
we find there are appropriate controls
in place to ensure information was only
accessed
where there was a valid business need
and we also found there was a document
retention schedule in place within um
which was in line with current
legislation and statutory requirements
we also found there was defined
procedures in place for the
appropriate disposal and destruction of
information
we noted two medium level findings first
was that the document retention and data
protection policies were out of
out of date at the time of the audit
however they have now been refreshed and
approved at the strategy and resources
committee
in november 2020 and that also included
an update
around digital records which obviously
weren't part of the audit scope
but good that that and that was included
within the refresh of the
the policies anyway secondly we noted um
a finding around the responsibilities of
information asset owners
those hadn't been appropriately defined
or communicated to those
named asset owners this is going to be
picked up um throughout
through the annual review of the asset
register which i believe is taking place
before may of this year
if there are any questions on the
information management report
do you have any questions from any of
the councillors for mrs donnelly
no okay lovely um thank you
oh that's luciana you've got your hand
up
yes thank you um just wanted to check if
i was reading something right it was on
page 55
and it there was the red block which was
talking about
um there was a significant risk that's
how i read it
and it seemed to be when i aligned it
that it was to do with
it was to do what you've just said about
the information managers
um and it mentioned with the high risk
that could i i think
um there are risks then a fraud and
other things
um obviously it's significant uh what is
you know what's being implemented have
we any indication of what's being done
to to marginalize that risk sorry
what page is this on on page 55
it was there was a red i think it was
page 55 i'm sorry i'll go back to where
i was
i think that's a key isn't it yeah the
page 55 is the appendix which shows the
definitions
so um red would be limited
which would be um a risk of fraud
however this report got
a medium moderate level uh
hold on a minute no i'm sure i've read
the wrong thing
oh i see right so that doesn't apply i
have read it the wrong way then so the
number of significant gaps there weren't
any
and you know there was two medium level
um findings which shows that there were
some gaps but
there is an appropriate action plan in
place one of which
has already been completed and the
second or one of which
and will be completed by the end of may
right
okay okay thank you thank you
okay is there any other questions for
miss donnelly
no before we move on to the
recommendations um just an answer to
councillor heard's question that um
there has been a report done by
damon geller and we will get it
circulated out to
all pg a members after this meeting
if that's okay thank you very
much thank you um so moving on to the
recommendations
um hang on i've just got an update from
burner
is there something else you wanted to
add to that burner no
german sorry it was just to say it's an
update from damien on both
both questions that came up at the last
meeting covering councillor heard's
issue
okay lovely thank you so the
recommendations set out in the report
are as follows that the council the
committee considers
comments and approves the one
the internal audit process report
december 2020 at apex 1
2 the internal audit sector report
january 2021 at opec appendix 2
3 the follow-up of recommendation report
december 2020 appendix 3
for the workforce management audit
november 2020
at appendix 4 and 5 the
information management december 2020
appendix 5. if any member wishes to
second that motion
can you please unmute your microphone
and state your name now
thank you councillor nan i think you
just beat councillor helm but
whichever burner one you've got um
lost the place now um
if everybody is happy to take that vote
by ex
uh a cent we can do so unless you want a
recorded vote
really great thank you thank you
agenda item seven balance scorecard
except exceptions report we move to a
gender item
seven balance score card found on pages
59-62
in a moment i will call on the officer
to present this item
members a reminder that if you wish to
speak on this item please make it known
by using the hands up function
and i will come to you in turn please
keep your points sear and succinct
miss hughes could you please present the
report
yes thank you chair um good afternoon
members
this report builds further on our
performance in sight and gives the
operational exceptions which is in
additional addition to the corporate
outcomes reporting that comes quarterly
to the committee
internally the extended leadership team
review a monthly performance dashboard
this covers reporting around financial
operational
customer and organizational and
statutory performance indicators
a full copy of this is available on the
members sharepoint
and what this report aims to do is draw
member attention
to the exceptions where either as a
council we're seeing
under performance or performance that
surpasses
targets in section 3.5
of the covering report the areas of
underperformance are highlighted
along with their associated management
response and action
there are five areas in this report and
they are
the percentage of business rates
collected the percentage of council
tax collected reps and bends of
outstanding cases and process
time commercial income delivery and
leisure participation and uptake
these have all been impacted in some way
by the changes of the pandemic and wider
economic issues
but the reporting allows us to track the
extent of the impact and then also
account for this
in the medium-term financial strategy
section 3.6 of the covering report
has the areas of over performance which
are highlighted
they are channel shift and website
feedback
a lot of work has taken place and
continues around digital improvements
under website refresh moving processes
online
and in addition these indicators are
also likely to have been impacted by the
pandemic in that there's been a general
customer move to online transactions
members are asked to review and comment
on this report
and be assured through this reporting
that operational performance is being
managed
effectively thank you
thank you for that counselor can i ask
you to turn your mic off
sorry i thought i had
and counselor none would you like to
ask yes thank you chair it's not really
a question it's just an observation
really to say that
given the troubled times we're living
through
and the hard work of the officers of
morton district council
i think the performance um is remarkably
good and it's not surprising
that there will be some hiccups along
the way
because of the emphasis on kovi's
support
but all in all this indicates to me that
um
officers are doing a grand job actually
yeah thank you councillor now
have i got any other questions for miss
hughes
uh councillor stamp you've got your hand
up
uh thank you it is um misused is
uh are we still working on the phones uh
because i still think there is an issue
that has been brought to me on numerous
occasions
and i see that we are over performing
support those who need it
in person and by phone have we got a
more up-to-date
uh information on this because in my
experience
we are struggling to actually meet this
target well my target which is nearly uh
we should be doing everything we can uh
but it says we're actually achieving
more than it so
a little bit of clarity for members on
that would be
greatly appreciated because i'm sure
other members are getting calls from
parish and town councils
when the district council isn't open uh
for enquiries
i'd appreciate that thank you thank you
chair so the specific indicator that's
been highlighted is channel shift
and this was around our um target that
we wanted to
encourage more transactions online so
that we had more time to help people
in person and by phone that needed um
help the more vulnerable people
and so actually where we've surpassed
our target
it's because 90 of our contact has been
online contact so it's where channel
shifts happened
and that's not necessarily to do with
the phone figures or phone contacts
um obviously we've you know we
operationally monitor
um things to do with the bones but we
don't have a particular target about
number of phone calls answered or
anything that's in the balance scorecard
at the moment
thank you through you chair um is there
a way that we can actually
uh audit that to do the telephones is
there a process that we can put
in place so this committee can have some
feedback on that
because in my experience it is an area
that we could
potentially improve on so is there
anything we can actually do at this
committee
please thank you so i could uh i'll
take that request back and look into the
data but there is
we could look at putting some phone data
um you know
percentage of calls answered within a
set amount of time or something like
that we'd need to look into the detail
and but we could look at putting phone
contact data into the report going
forwards yep
um just to come back councillor stamp we
do have a meeting
with uh miss green and mr holmes
i think on monday so we can
chair i know that but the rest of the
members don't know that and i'm really
keen that everybody's included to know
exactly what's going on if you forgive
me but thank you
that's fine uh councillor heard
um thank you chairman yes on 3.6 the
over-performing uh
i mean i i see that as good news
actually
if you've got uh 90 of the contact
online
uh i think that's quite a remarkable
achievement bearing in mind the
demographics
uh of the malden district is is mainly
um older people
um and you know the increase in website
feedback
i i think that's to be commended i think
very good
thank you councillor any other questions
council have heard you still get your
hand up
i'm sorry that's a legacy thank you any
other questions for ms hughes
no thank you cheryl for that report um
we move on to the recommendations the
recommendations are set out within the
report as follows
recommendation one that the committee
review and comment on exceptions to
service reporting provided in this
report
an item and two that members confirm
they are stored through this review
operational performance is being managed
effectively
any member that wishes to second that
motion please turn on your microphone
now and state your name
i'll second that thank you councillor
helm
uh berna we will take a vote um
for these recommendations so are the
committee
uh are all the councillors happy to
accept by ascent
[Music]
thank you very much yes agreed
so agenda item
eight the annual governance statement
actions update we move to agenda item
eight
the annual government statement actions
update found on pages 63-66
in a moment i will call on the officer
to present this item
members a reminder that if you wish to
speak on this item please make this
known by using the hands up
function within this meeting i will then
come to you in turn
please keep your points clear and
succinct
miss hughes please present the report
thank you so members for the first time
in the 1920 annual governance statement
although there were no significant areas
of governance concerned
we identified some aspirational actions
around
best practice for future governance
the annual governance statement was
approved as part of the statement of
accounts at council on
the 13th of december 2020 although it
was separately approved by performance
governance and audit committee
on the 30th of july 2020.
so this is the first time that we're
bringing an update on the actions that
were defined
um now that the mechanism has been set
up
and in the in july the committee also
resolved to see
this reported quarterly going forwards
section 3.4 of the covering report
has a table that gives details of the
actions and the commentary on their
progress
it may be that depending on levels of
progress some of these actions will also
be rolled over and included in the 2021
annual governance statement too members
are
invited to review the annual governance
statement action table and the updates
and challenge where appropriate thank
you
thank you are there any questions for
miss hughes
councillor none well again chair if
you'll indulge me not a question but an
observation
on page 65 cheryl the very last
uh issue there that's got paul's name
against it
monitoring the impacts of covid you know
that's going to be all
important going forward isn't it because
that has a knock-on effect in terms of
the delivery of other elements of the
service
so i i do think that that is that is
very much a requirement going forward to
look at what really has happened as a
result of the
emphasis that's had to be placed on
kovid's support
thank you thank you i i
should imagine that a significant focus
in in the next annual governance
statement we'll we'll be around that as
well
thank you cheryl uh councillor channel
you've got your hand up
hold on that's it trying to get back to
there it's just an observation if i may
and it's not
um criticism as such but there's quite a
few
acronyms in there and um i just think it
might be helpful for the public who read
the reports
if perhaps the first time they use they
could be given in full
because obviously it's a public document
and even i my myself i'll be honest i've
read a couple
and thought right hang on what does that
mean they were saying like e-l-t
to you know blah blah blah p to pmo
and i i just thought remember the public
would not
really um comprehend that so that's just
an observation
yeah noted and i'll update that for the
next one
thank you counselor channel acronyms are
awful i used to have to use them and
you can mis take them different ways um
your hand is still up council channel
thank you so we'll move on to the
recommendations if there's no other
questions for
miss hughes so the recommendations
within the report are as follows
recommendation one to review the ags
action table and update and challenge
where appropriate
so if any member wishes to second that
motion please turn on
your microphone thank you councillor
helm
um do members happy to take this by
a saint agreed greatly thank you
moving on um to item nine
any other items of business that the
chairman decides are
urgent i only have one and it's just to
inform all members of the council that
we are looking up at setting up a
working group
it come on the next council agenda
we feel that some things it would be
best to have a working group looking at
them
and then bringing a report back to this
so we can update you more on that
as we go that is the only item that i've
got
so there'd be no other
business i will close this meeting
members thank you for your contribution
this mate
this afternoon i draw the meeting closed
at
14 36 i would like to thank all the
officers
that have given reports for their
excellent reports and i would like to
thank everybody for
attending i would also like to say to
you that with the weather conditions
please be safe out there
as the meeting is now closed members are
advised not to enter into any further
discussion on this forum
and please leave the meeting promptly
thank you very much